hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 19 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet all kinds of flashpoint things
happening now I was so happy that they
brought back killer frost they they kind
of tied up that storyline in a way that
let you know that this isn't the last
we've seen of killer frost that's one of
the most beautiful things about the
multiverse is that you can have moments
like this where you're like holy
did zoom just phase through Caitlin to
grab an icicle midair and stab her but
wait there's the multiverse so there's
an infinite number of other killer
Frost's to go out and see so let's do
top 10 WTF
I'll explain Easter eggs as we go along
there's a lot of really exciting stuff
happening now I think the direction
things are going will repair a lot of
the damage that people felt after last
week's zoom back story reveal here we go
number 10 opening monologue just a funny
twist of showing how Berry's life is
different now that he's back to normal
the title of the episode was back to
normal so by the end of the episode
everybody's relationships were back to
normal but of course they're gonna have
fun with a twist on him getting ready in
the morning they did a little bit of
that in season 1 we're like right after
he got his powers they did the funny
montage where he's getting ready at
SuperSpeed or like when he's getting
ready for dates at SuperSpeed so now
Barry has to learn to be a hero
using his regular skills he's actually
trained as a CSI and he's pretty good at
it so he can still be a hero part of the
episode is learning that so number 9 WTF
Barry isn't the only person who is upset
at what's happened Harrison wells is
just like flying off the deep end
because now zoom can come and go as he
pleases Jesse's still in trouble but he
finds a way to track her down using the
vibrational frequencies of different
earths that'll also probably come back
in a future episode too especially
because of the zoom teaser at the end of
the episode number 8 WTF Caitlin and
zoom I'm not talking to you when you're
wearing that use your indoor voice Darth
Vader
I love the zoom is like totally off the
deep end crazy now he is off the rails I
feel like he's gonna be a lot of fun and
they addressed the idea of Caitlin being
the damsel in distress I'm so happy with
what they did with Caitlin in this
episode she's not just gonna sit there
and wait for someone to rescue her she's
smart she even concocts a plan to escape
with number 7 killer frost oh this was
so much fun so much awesome killer frost
Caitlin scenes but they could have done
a whole episode with just the two of
them talking to each
there is your mama on earth 1 2
mine's been a ever since our
little brother died which i think is an
Easter Egg for Kaitlyn's backstory on
earth one that each season we just learn
a little bit more about their lives
outside of STAR Labs so it just gets so
much more interesting
so maybe earth one Caitlin learned a
secret about her mother here that her
mother had never told her
but back and forth you kind of get the
idea that they're really the same person
they share a lot of personality traits
it's really the decisions they've made
that differentiates them like killer
frost is all about showing the girls off
I totally love that she was boob shaming
Caitlin but number 6 WTF killer frost
turns on Caitlin is gonna try and do the
same thing that dr. light was going to
do to earth 1 Linda Park take her place
so the zoom can't tell the difference
zoom TLAs Caitlin so killer frost is
going to try to become Caitlin so the
zoom won't kill her but too late and
this is actually probably my favorite
action scene zoom phases right through
Caitlin to grab the icicle and stab her
with it you're right I don't need you
anymore
number five WTF Griffin grey vs. team
flash I wasn't a huge fan of the actors
performance but I did like that they
were grabbing a character from the
comics and his comic book story has
changed just a little bit so in the
comics he gives off this green energy
they just changed it and made him super
strong on the TV show but it works the
same way the more he uses his powers the
older he gets so in the comics he steals
a bunch of stuff from STAR Labs to try
and reverse his condition it doesn't
work he ends up using his abilities so
much that it kills him like his heart
just gives out from exhaustion from old
age but how cool was it that Felicity
lone team flashed the dwarf star alloy
to beef up his costume
speedy wish number four Jesse quick is
back on team flash now Jesse I need some
of that quick mind there's so many comic
book Jesse quick hat tips going on when
she's on screen is so much fun and her
t-shirt game is totally on point fun no
fun
she's stealing a lot of Cisco thunder
and I totally love it when they finished
filming the finale last week or the week
before I can't remember exactly which
day it was they posted this picture so
I'm pretty sure that she's gonna be in
every single episode from now till the
finale that's episode 23 so what I'm
really hoping is is that you know
wherever they leave things in the finale
it allows her to stay on for season 3
because I'd love for her to be a main
cast member or at least regular
recurring so that even if she's not in
every single episode she's in a lot more
episodes than she was in last year a
great father-daughter moment promise me
you won't run away
I guess there's gonna be a speed force
exception to that rule I'm not expecting
her to get speed force powers anytime
soon
you never know it's just the idea that
the Jessie quake if she got speed force
powers might be a little closer to the
comics and have something to do with the
speed formula which they actually had on
one of the boards in an earlier episode
but number two WTF zoom teases
conquering other Earth's so who knows
how many others were gonna get to see
but it definitely seems like we're gonna
see a version of another earth so it
remains to be seen which earth that is
but I love the idea that they're taking
the time to use the multiverse in a
really big way it would have been super
disappointing if they had only given us
earth to like oh we're only gonna go to
this one other earth this season but
we've gotten to go to Supergirl so
technically that's another earth so now
they're just gonna go even further
beyond that in number one WTF you know
big big flashpoint Easter Egg they're
going to cause another particle
accelerator explosion to try and get
Barry his powers back so the deal with
flashpoint if you guys haven't seen it
is is the flash loses his ability
because of something the reverse flash
does to create a paradox so in order to
get his powers back Barry has to
recreate the accident that gave him
powers I kind of explained this in last
week's video so I don't really know too
much but essentially that's what's going
on here they're recreating the accident
that originally gave him powers to try
and get him powers again and in the
comics it totally worked so I'm guessing
it's gonna work on the TV show but let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode do you think Barry is
gonna get his powers back because of the
new particle accelerator explosion or
something else gonna happen and what do
you think about the wally west arc now
they've just been teasing that he's
really happy about making the most of
his second chance so I'm curious to see
if he creates something with his
engineering skills that helps the flash
to feed zoom or helps him get his powers
back somehow but it's definitely going
somewhere there's something going on
here beyond Wally just being really
happy about making the most of his life
like the next step is him being inspired
to create something that really does
help the flash giveaway time the new
round of the giveaway starts now it's a
$20 Amazon gift card all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video there's a new
episode of arrow new legends of tomorrow
and there's a whole bunch of DC stuff
going on so there'll be a bunch more DC
videos this week and I know that
some more spider-man footage that
dropped tonight I'll totally do a video
for it but it probably won't post till
tomorrow morning while you guys wait for
me to post that video you can click here
for my Melisandre Game of Thrones
episode 1 explainer video and you can
click here for last week's episode of
the flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight